[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON ANDREAS: Guys,
thanks for coming.
This is Talks at Google.
My name is Jason Andreas.
I'm here with Dr.
Howard Markel, author
of "The Kelloggs: The Battling
Brothers of Battle Creek."
This book actually 2017 National
Book Critics Circle Award
finalist for nonfiction.
So congratulations on that.
HOWARD MARKEL: Thank you.
JASON ANDREAS:
The paperback just
came out today as we were just
discussing a little bit ago.
Let's please give Dr.
Markel a big Google welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
So we were talking about
this a little bit earlier.
The book is quite thick for
those of you that can't see.
It's fantastically
a detailed recount
of the Kellogg brothers.
How did you initially
become interested in writing
this book?
Where did the spark come from
to kind of dig into these two
brothers lives and really
kind of flesh it out
as much as you have?
HOWARD MARKEL: Well,
this was really
a great leap from
my previous work
where I've written quite
a bit about epidemics.
And the book before this
one was about Sigmund Freud
and his discovery of
cocaine, which he'd
liked a little bit too much.
JASON ANDREAS: We've
heard the stories.
HOWARD MARKEL: He
was a wild man.
And actually this project began
as a project of convenience,
which I've never done before and
hopefully won't do soon after.
But I had just injured
my back terribly
while I was finishing the
research for the last book.
I injured myself in Vienna
and herniated a disk
and then a second disk.
So I wasn't very mobile.
And I knew that John Harvey
Kellogg's papers were mostly
at the Bentley
Historical Library
at the University of Michigan.
So I started playing with them.
And I'd known about him.
But the more I played with
the papers and looked at them,
I figured, well, there was a
book in that life and the span
of time he lived
in American history
and in American medicine.
But as I wrote more and
more about the book,
I realized that if you told
the story of John Harvey
Kellogg the doctor,
you had to also tell
the story of his little brother
Will Kellogg, the Corn Flake
king, because they
worked together
for 25 years at the
Battle Creek Sanitarium.
They co-invented what
became Corn Flakes.
And then they ruptured
their relationship.
And, of course, Kellogg's became
the world famous food giant
that it is today.
JASON ANDREAS: Well, I think
one of the interesting things
about the book is the
dynamic between the brothers.
You start off by kind of laying
a foundation of how they got
to the United States, and
how they settled in Michigan,
and really foundationally
from a geography standpoint.
But then you start to explain
how they were each brought up
differently.
John, for the most part, had
a pretty easy path in life,
we'll say.
He was always kind of
the favorite child.
Everyone who met him said he was
this great intelligent person,
and went through
multiple medical schools,
was always kind of
lauded in his time.
Where Will on the other
side was initially
seen as being dimwitted,
which eventually--
HOWARD MARKEL: That's the
word his teacher used.
JASON ANDREAS:
Dimwitted-- I know.
I don't use that word
often in my life.
That's a quote, which was
ultimately kind of attributed
to nearsightedness, I
believe, eventually.
HOWARD MARKEL: Which wasn't
diagnosed until he was 20.
JASON ANDREAS: Which
is why, I know.
HOWARD MARKEL: So imagine that.
JASON ANDREAS: But
I think that plays
into too when he eventually
started his foundation.
A lot of what they do-- we'll
talk about that a little
later--
is focus on children's health,
kids' health, and eyesight
in general as well.
[INAUDIBLE]
HOWARD MARKEL:
Ocular Eye health.
In fact, the University of
Michigan Kellogg Eye Center,
that's not by accident.
JASON ANDREAS:
Sure, of course not.
He had a little bit of
a harder kind of life
where a lot of folks
were not as nice to him.
Even his parents didn't
necessarily treat him as well.
He sold brooms for
his family, where
his brother was off at
these fancy medical schools
across the country.
Yet, when you think of
the Kellogg name now,
especially, people probably
associate more with Will.
He's got kind of the longer
legacy that's lasted.
How did you go about kind
of deciphering the play
between the two brothers?
If we transported ourselves back
to the late 1800s, early 1900s,
John would probably be the
more famous of the two.
HOWARD MARKEL: Absolutely.
JASON ANDREAS: Whereas
100 years later Plus,
now Will is kind of the one
who's left the longer legacy.
How did you go about kind of
breaking that apart and really
also tying it together as well?
HOWARD MARKEL: Well, you
make a very good point.
In real time, John
Harvey Kellogg
was one of most famous
doctors in America.
He was a best-selling author.
He lectured all over.
The Battle Creek Sanitarium
was a very popular place
where tens of
thousands of people
came to this medical
resort/spa/grand hotel/hospital
because they did operations, and
medical treatments, and so on.
And during that period, Will
called himself JH's lackey.
And it wasn't until Corn Flakes
became a product that the name
Kellogg became synonymous
with Will's work.
What was great about writing
about both these brothers
was the conflict.
And so as a writer,
I love conflict.
I don't like it in my own life.
But I love it when I'm writing
about other people's lives.
And it's a great
tool that I've used
as a literary device
for many of my books
to go back and forth
between two or more people
because it makes the story far
more interesting and richer.
And it brings the reader--
when they're in one place,
they want to go to the
next place, and so on.
So it's a way of holding
the interests of the reader,
but also of the writer.
Because if the writer is
not interested in the book,
it's very hard to convey
that to an audience.
So I found their relationship
just fascinating.
And each of them were
remarkable in their own way.
And yet, they were
probably at their best
when they worked together even
though they were at their worst
when they worked together.
John Harvey treated
Will very badly.
He would make him run
around beside him as he
rode his bicycle to take notes.
If he was having one of his
five daily bowel movements--
the doctor is a big believer
in that he had constipation--
he would make Will come into
the bathroom and take dictation,
I mean, all these kind
of demeaning things.
He paid him very badly.
Will rarely had a day off.
And yet, Will ran the
place beautifully.
His great genius was in
business, and administration,
in process.
He had to manage all these
people, different types
of people, doctors, nurses,
orderlies, masseuses,
hydrotherapists,
cooks, you name it.
And so you couldn't
find a better place
to learn how to run an
international corporation
like Kellogg's than running
the Battle Creek Sanitarium
for his brother Dr. Kellogg.
JASON ANDREAS: Sure.
I grew up with an older brother.
As I was reading the
book, I kept laughing.
I was like, jeez, I
thought my brother was
mean to me when I was young.
This guy was pretty
rough on his brother.
But, again, ultimately I loved
the dynamic, like you said.
It's really interesting.
It was almost like a script
for a movie or something
where you've got the one
brother who is super successful,
the other who is not.
And they end up kind of crossing
paths as the story continues.
And, again, as you
said ultimately,
they worked best together.
But ultimately, they also had a
difficult relationship as well.
[INAUDIBLE]
HOWARD MARKEL: Because
their greatest moment,
their great eureka moment, was
coming up with flaked cereals.
First, it was wheat.
Then it was corn because it
was cheaper and tasted better.
And then it tasted
even better when
Will added a little
sugar and salt
that the doctor was against.
But if you think
about corn flakes,
it changed the way
people ate breakfast.
Because breakfast was
an ordeal, particularly
in an era of wood burning stoves
and when mothers were really
the primary homemakers.
They would have to get up
early to start the fire.
They would make, for example,
bacon, or salted meats,
or fried potatoes.
Or even if you made
oatmeal, it was a big to-do.
Now you could just simply
pour breakfast out of a box.
Even dad could make it.
So really in 1906
when it came out,
it took the world by storm.
JASON ANDREAS:
Truly revolutionary.
I mean, we take it
for granted today.
I've got 10 boxes of
cereal in my pantry.
But you don't think
about that this
was a revolutionary kind of
introduction when it came out
in the early 1900s.
HOWARD MARKEL: Yeah, and it
was made as a health food.
It was made for
invalids who could not
digest their food very easily.
And indeed, flaked cereals are
perhaps too easy to digest.
You break it down as soon
as you start eating it.
And in fact, we
know that has what's
called a high glycemic index,
meaning it raises your blood
sugar and then your insulin.
And then it
precipitously goes down.
Then you're hungry long
before noon, before lunch,
while a low glycemic index,
oatmeal, you stay full
or you feel full longer.
But Will's brilliant
idea was that there's
a lot more regular
healthy people who
need a nutritious breakfast
than sick people who
need a health food breakfast.
And so that was his brilliance.
JASON ANDREAS: Can
you talk about--
you mentioned this a lot.
And this is a recurring
theme in the book
is both John and Will's
obsession with kind
of this healthy lifestyle,
which was actually fairly
revolutionary at the time too.
You lay a foundation
early on, as I mentioned,
of what kind of a difficult
time the late 1800s were.
Their family grew up kind of
on the west side of Michigan,
a little bit on the frontier
and how unhealthy people were
at this time and how they
kind of revolutionized
this idea of health,
this idea of wellness.
HOWARD MARKEL: Of
wellness, wellness.
JASON ANDREAS:
Yeah, wellness, kind
of this all encompassing,
which included things
like eating better, but also
exercise, and fresh air,
and all of these
different things.
HOWARD MARKEL: No nicotine,
no alcohol, no caffeine.
JASON ANDREAS: Which
was a complete U-turn
for a lot of people at the time.
Can you talked a
little bit about how
they were raised in that era
and how they kind utilized
that motivation to
focus their life
on this idea of well-being,
both of them did?
[INAUDIBLE]
HOWARD MARKEL: And
their parents who
came from Massachusetts to
Michigan really were pioneers.
And when they came
in the 1830s, they
came before Michigan
was even a state.
It was still a territory.
And one of their
brothers describes a wall
of trees on either side
of a little dirt road
that they took originally
to Flint, then to Jackson,
and then to Battle Creek.
But people ate remarkably
badly in the 19th century.
JASON ANDREAS: Butter, lard.
HOWARD MARKEL:
Vegetables were always
cream, a lot of butter, a lot
of lard, a lot of animal fat.
You would save the
grease from dinner
to fry up breakfast
the next morning.
Lot of molasses, and syrup, and
heavily sugared foods, a lot
of alcohol.
The consumption of
alcohol in say 1900
if you look at the
data is staggering,
which gives you a lot of reasons
why people wanted prohibition
in the late '20s.
JASON ANDREAS: It
was out of control.
HOWARD MARKEL:
Yeah, and a lot of--
people smoked.
And they drank a lot of
coffee, a lot of tea.
So the American diet
was not a good one.
Now the Kelloggs
were early acolytes
of the Seventh Day
Adventist Church,
which has a great many edicts.
They were based in Battle Creek.
Now one of the most famous is
the prediction of the advent,
the second coming
of Jesus Christ,
and the destruction
of the mortal world,
and the good people
going up to heaven.
That's what really well known.
But even more intriguing to
me as a historian of medicine
was the founders of the
church, Ellen and James White,
their edicts on what they
called health reform.
So the idea was that
your body is a temple.
If you want to go to
heaven, you not only
have to be clean of mind and
spirit, but also of body.
And so she worked with a
lot of people of that era
in terms of healthy diets,
of wellness, as you said.
Dr. Kellogg called
it biologic living.
But they work with people
like Sylvester Graham of--
JASON ANDREAS: Graham Crackers.
HOWARD MARKEL:
--Graham Cracker fame.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah, of course.
HOWARD MARKEL: And that
was a whole wheat grain
that he recommended.
And there were many other
people, vegetarians and such.
They were not the
majority, but they
were saying this is what
we ought to be eating,
this is how we ought to
be exercising and taking
care of ourselves, spiritually--
the issues of worry,
and not sleeping well,
things like that.
It's just remarkable
how much they suggested.
And if you look at
the early progress
in American public health,
it is very intricately
tied to Christianity in
various sects of Christianity
that are telling their flock
to take care of themselves.
JASON ANDREAS: You also talk
about a conflicting idea though
with the Adventists
as well in terms of--
since they thought that
the Advent was coming
and there was this ultimate
return of the creator,
that they put kind
of a low focus
on like higher education
and lasting education.
Yet, coming up in a very
religious kind of base,
both brothers became kind
of revolutionary in the way
that they kind of tackled
some of these things.
They were kind of difference
makers in their fields
where it seems
really interesting
because they did
focus on education,
whereas the
religious [INAUDIBLE]
HOWARD MARKEL: Yeah,
yeah, I mean, Will
was not educated beyond grade
school because his parents
thought, what's the point?
JASON ANDREAS: What's the point?
HOWARD MARKEL: And
a lot of people
felt that in that community.
It is interesting though
that even the Whites,
who are predicting
an Advent, they're
much more careful than
other denominations that
are saying the same thing in
that they're not giving a date.
JASON ANDREAS: Right, yeah.
HOWARD MARKEL: That was
really quite brilliant.
JASON ANDREAS: Predicting 2022.
HOWARD MARKEL: There was
one guy, William Miller, who
predicted this particular date.
It didn't happen.
JASON ANDREAS: It's good to
predict the day if it works.
If not, you basically
lose your credibility.
HOWARD MARKEL:
Well, if it works,
that's not so good
either considering
what you're predicting.
JASON ANDREAS: [INAUDIBLE]
HOWARD MARKEL: But
at the same time,
the Whites were
building an empire.
They were building churches
all over the country
and then later, the world.
They had missionaries going
out to bring more people in.
They had a huge
publishing company
that published a
newspaper, Bible tracks,
all sorts of things.
It's sort of an early Google.
They are transmitting
information
using 19th century
methods of technology
but to spread the word.
And John Harvey was sent to good
medical schools by the Whites.
They paid for it because
they wanted someone
to run what was then called
the Western Health Reform
Institute, which ultimately
became the Battle Creek
Sanitarium.
So they could see far
enough into the future
to take care of things that
would extend their empire.
JASON ANDREAS: Can you talk a
little bit about the sanitarium
because it's in the
story of the Kelloggs?
And, again, if we shot
back to the late 1800s,
everyone would know about
the Battle Creek Sanitarium.
A lot of folks might not
know as much about it.
Again, you say the word
Kellogg's a lot of folks
would obviously think about the
food brand or the foundation.
They wouldn't necessarily think
about the sanitarium itself.
So can you talk a little bit
about what the sanitarium was?
You talked a little
bit about how
it started with the Whites kind
of educating John and bringing
him back.
But what did that look
like back in the day?
Why was it such an important
part of health and wellness
at the time?
HOWARD MARKEL: Well, it
started basically in 1866
as a little house with
some quacky doctors
and some pretty bad food.
They used to give a lot of
what was called hydrotherapy,
baths of all kind.
But they didn't always
have enough water.
So sometimes they had
a reuse the bathwater
on different patients,
which for some reason
was not well received.
One woman said, it's
as if we were all
dipped into the same gravy.
And when John Harvey
came back in 1876
from going to Bellevue Hospital
Medical College in New York
City, he said, I'll do it on
a couple of conditions, one,
that I get to run it
as the most modern
medical and scientifically
oriented place I can muster.
And, two, I don't
want any interference
from the religious elders.
He did not want
laypeople to tell him
how to run his hospital.
But he was very, very ambitious.
And he kept building
on and more and more
to the Battle Creek Sanitarium.
It became bigger and better
with each passing year.
The Battle Creek Sanitarium
was the most popular train stop
on the Michigan Central Railway
between Detroit and Chicago.
And as I said earlier, more
than 10,000 people a year
came there for all sorts
of therapies, and spas,
and lectures.
He called it a sanitarium.
He made that name up--
sanitas from health,
Latin for health.
And it was his
university of health.
It was there not just to be a
hospital where sick people were
treated, but where
people came to be well
and to lead healthy lives.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah, absolutely.
You talked about John's
experience in Bellevue.
And to go back a
little bit about kind
of the dynamic of
health at the time,
you mentioned that the mortality
rate at Bellevue Hospital,
which is one of the most famous
in the country at the time,
was 16 or 17%--
HOWARD MARKEL: Oh, it was huge.
JASON ANDREAS: --or
something like that.
So basically out
of every 100 people
who checked into the hospital,
only around 80 of them
actually left.
HOWARD MARKEL: Went home.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah,
which if that happened
at University of Michigan,
we'd be in a lot of trouble
right now, right?
HOWARD MARKEL: Yeah, not you.
I would.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah, sure.
HOWARD MARKEL: You
don't work there.
But, first of all,
so this is 1874.
And think about
what medicine had
to treat people at that time.
And the answer is
not a whole lot.
JASON ANDREAS: Not much, yeah.
HOWARD MARKEL: And
most of hospital care
was what we would call
today nursing care.
There was no IV fluids.
That didn't happen
till the 1930s.
Surgery in terms of antiseptic
and the later aseptic surgery
so you don't die of a
post-operative infection
was just beginning at the time.
So, generally, an operation
could end up in death.
And you didn't do a lot
of exploratory surgery
inside the gut, let
alone the chest.
It was largely amputations
or external procedures.
There were very few drugs
that would treat diseases.
And so people did not
live very long and healthy
lives, particularly
those who went
to hospitals like Bellevue.
This was a public
hospital for the poor.
The rich would never
find themselves
at Bellevue Hospital.
And there was a
distinction of how
the poor were taken care of
as opposed to how the wealthy.
Sound familiar?
That's not a problem
we have yet solved.
But it was not a healthy
place to find yourself,
and most people back when
John Harvey Kellogg walked
the wards of Bellevue
would avoid it at all costs
if they could.
JASON ANDREAS: Can you talk
about some of the methods
for treating diseases--
bleeding, use of
mercury, things like
that I mean you're [INAUDIBLE].
HOWARD MARKEL:
Arsenic, strychnine.
JASON ANDREAS: How
could this be possible?
But, again, 150 years
ago these were fairly--
HOWARD MARKEL:
These were standard.
JASON ANDREAS:
[INAUDIBLE] experimental.
HOWARD MARKEL: But
a lot of laypeople
don't read a lot of the
history of medicine.
Don't understand fully is
that while a lot of people
were called MD, that they've
graduated from a college that
gave them that degree,
different schools taught
different forms of medicine.
So the University of
Michigan, for example,
taught what's called allopathic
medicine, which is still what
is practiced, what my MD is in.
And that's the notion
of medications,
or drugs, and
operations, and so on.
But they're also homeopaths.
In fact, University
of Michigan used
to have a homeopathic
medical school
from the 1870s to
the early 1920s, who
taught that infinitesimally
small doses of a drug that
created the same symptoms
of the disease you had
would be curative.
There were osteopaths.
There were botanical doctors.
There were eclectic doctors.
So not all MDs were alike.
And even if you were from
the best medical school
of that era, what
was being taught
and what you had in your
arsenal was pitifully small
compared to today or even
compared to 50 years ago.
JASON ANDREAS: I'm glad things
have progressed beyond the--
HOWARD MARKEL: Me too.
JASON ANDREAS: --the 1920s
when it comes to medicine.
Progressing forward
a little bit,
then so from the
sanitarium in Battle Creek,
where did the kind of invention
of corn flakes come to be?
How did that progress
from kind of this health
retreat to now creating
what would eventually
become the Kellogg's Company?
HOWARD MARKEL: Yeah, well,
John Henry Kellogg-- one
of his big pursuits as a
scientist was inventing foods.
He had a food laboratory.
And he thought there are certain
healthy or healthier foods.
He was a big fan of nuts.
In fact, he probably
invented peanut butter.
People always
disagree about that.
And his peanut butter was
made out of boiled peanuts
and didn't taste very good.
But he came up with foods that
were palatable because eating
mushy, overcooked
vegetables or grains
is not really attractive.
And he wanted people
to eat healthy
when they left the
sanitarium, as well as when
they were at the sanitarium.
And so one of his
theories was that if you
took a starch in a grain and
you cooked it or baked it
for a long period of time, you
broke down the starch molecules
into a simple sugar dextrose.
And he called that
dextrinization.
And that would be
easier to digest.
And a lot of people
with bad stomachs
would come to the sanitarium.
I mean, after dyspepsia,
stomach aches, constipation,
autointoxication,
where pieces of meat
were theorized to be
festering in your gut
and giving off poisons, they
all came to Battle Creek.
And so he first fed them
double-baked biscuits,
Zwieback.
And the way the story goes,
whether it's true or not--
a woman bit into a
biscuit and broke
her dentures and
demanded $10, which
was quite a lot of money
in 1880 from the doctor
to pay for the dentures.
Well, he didn't want to do
that for other patients.
So he came up with
different ways
that people wouldn't have
to bite into a hard biscuit.
First, he ground it down.
And it became a
little tiny particles.
He called that granola until
somebody sued him because they
had the name granola.
JASON ANDREAS: They
had already made it.
Yeah.
HOWARD MARKEL: And then
they called it granos.
And then he played around
with batches of dough--
will and John did
this for years--
of how to cook it,
boil it, bake it.
So it was both dextinized,
it was easy to digest,
but also palatable
and reproducible.
But you can make a lot of it.
And they finally
hit on flaked cereal
one day when they
had a batch of dough.
They had worked all week.
And they were very tired.
And the doctor was
either called away
for a medical
emergency or they just
both wanted to just go to bed.
And Will was very cheap.
So he took that batch of dough
and put it in a container
overnight.
And probably what happened
is that the dough tempered.
And tempering is a process where
the water content in a dough
evens out across
the entire batch.
And you don't get air bubbles.
And it's a little moldy,
but not too moldy.
Then it alters the taste.
Bakers know about
this quite well.
But they didn't.
And then when they rolled it
out very flat and baked it,
and then it would cut
little pieces off,
they got perfect flakes.
And so that's how wheat
flakes of flaked cereal
were developed.
And then Will went
back to the lab
and tried this batch,
and that batch,
and adding this,
or taking this out.
And then eventually they
came up with corn flakes.
JASON ANDREAS: And this was
healthy at the time compared
to the other ways
that they were eating.
I think it's interesting--
so both of the brothers in their
pursuit with the sanitarium
then ultimately
with corn flakes,
they were really kind of after
this like American pursuit
of wellness or kind
of credited for this.
And you talk about
that a lot in the book.
But when you mention
the name Kelloggs today,
again, bringing
it to present day,
it's not necessarily
synonymous with wellness.
I don't say John Kellogg
or Will Kellogg--
oh yeah, they've created
this whole American movement
of wellness.
In fact, as I was talking to
people about this talk today
with you, and I mentioned the
word Kellogg's, I would just
kind of ask them, what do
you think of when you hear
Kellogg's?
A lot of the responses
are Frosted Flakes,
Frosted Mini-Wheats, Pop Tarts.
Like all of these sugary treats.
And now, obviously, that's
probably a product of time.
This is not something that
they created initially.
So the name Kellogg's and
wellness don't necessarily
go completely together.
What's the lasting legacy of all
of this work that they put in
to establish this base
of American wellness
and how it looks today?
What do you think the legacy
of the brothers is based on?
HOWARD MARKEL: Well, a
couple of things-- first,
I can tell your age
because you called it
Frosted Flakes and not
Sugar Frosted Flakes
JASON ANDREAS: Sugar
Frosted Flakes.
[INAUDIBLE]
HOWARD MARKEL: Which is what
they were called in the 1960s.
They are great.
JASON ANDREAS: Fair.
HOWARD MARKEL: They are great.
They're fantastic.
That actually happened after
Will died in the mid '50s.
There was another CEO
who noticed, particularly
in the television
era, that cartoon
characters and sugary
cereals sold like hotcakes.
And of course, they did.
Will cereals-- he prided
himself on knowing
a lot about nutrition and
making nutritious cereal.
So his product
line was basically
Corn Flakes, Rice
Krispies, and bran cereals,
and later shredded wheat.
And most of those while
they're not perfect cereals,
we'd consider them healthier
than the products you just
mentioned.
The doctor was against
added sugar completely.
JASON ANDREAS: In
any way, right?
HOWARD MARKEL: In any way.
He called them sugar inebriates.
These were not ingredients
that he would have advocated.
And the Kellogg's
Food Company today
is a conglomerate of, I
think, 180 different brands.
JASON ANDREAS: And many
of them very healthy.
HOWARD MARKEL: Some
healthy, some not.
And the other notion
too by the way
is they're processed
food, which today
is sort of a dirty, dirty word.
JASON ANDREAS: Processed,
chemically altered foods.
HOWARD MARKEL: But
then it represented
the advent of modernity because
you took a product, corn,
and you ran it through five
miles of conveyor belts,
and baking, and toasting,
and this, and that.
And it came out a completely
different product, corn flakes,
that does not exist in nature.
You are processing and
manufacturing food.
And so at the time, they were
thought to be very healthy.
What the company does to make
their reputation healthier
is up to them.
They have not asked
me for advice.
But if we think about
wellness and a lot of products
that the doctor
advocate, including
soy milk, and almond milk, and
probiotics, and the lifestyle
he suggested, we may
not think of his name.
But we do think of his
prescriptions all the time.
And I think the doctor
would have preferred
to have been known
for that, but was also
enough of a zealot for
his cause that he'd say,
it's OK as long as people
are living healthier lives.
JASON ANDREAS: You talk a
lot in the book too about--
you talk about the legacy.
And you mentioned
this as well with
some of the modernization
of some of the foods
that Kellogg's produces now.
About the movement
that Will in particular
started around just advertising
in general and brand
advertising, which
we all know so well--
a lot of us are in
advertising here at Google.
And so that struck a
chord with me as well.
He spent a lot of
money on advertising
when Corn Flakes and
subsequent cereals came out.
He kind of spearheaded some
of these ideas around jingles,
and catchphrases, and as you
mentioned, cartoon characters.
He also kind of had
some early inclinations
of how to kind of
market cereals and foods
in particular to children with
putting toys in cereal boxes.
HOWARD MARKEL: Yeah, he
invented the toy in the box.
JASON ANDREAS: A lot
came from him, right?
It was obviously carried on and
duplicated across the board.
I think that's a really
interesting concept too is not
only were they
revolutionary in terms
of food production, and
health, and wellness,
but also that extended into
the business world as well.
HOWARD MARKEL: Yeah, yeah.
It is incredible.
What was so much
fun about this book
is that even though it's about
two brothers in a small city,
it's sort of like spokes on
a wheel of American history
at that time and how Will
seized on advertising
at that moment in 1906 on.
It's just when three
and four color printing
is beginning, when Linotype
machines are being developed,
when national magazines and
newspapers are requiring
advertisements to
fill their pages.
And his big demographic
were basically
children, who had
asked their mothers.
And mothers were the
other demographic
who bought the food.
And he advertised to
both those demographics
fairly well in all
sorts of creative ways
that we now take for granted.
And he also was very early
an advertiser on radio, then
television, and I suspect on
Google, and the internet today.
He was brilliant at that.
Other things were happening
in American industry too that
helped Kellogg's
become Kellogg's.
You had a shift from
coal-burning factories
to electrical-powered factories,
so you could start and stop
your conveyor belt at
the push of a button.
You had all sorts of new
machinery, and conveyor belts,
and toasting ovens, and so on.
You had good railways that
went across the country
and had refrigerated cars.
You had clean
pasteurized milk that
was just starting
to be distributed
in America at that time.
And you can't have a
bowl of corn flakes
unless you have some milk.
So that was going on as well.
You had the telephones.
So Will could call up Iowa
from his Battle Creek office
and say, what's the
corn production?
What's going on?
And you could instantly make
your plans based on that.
And so all these advents
of new technologies
occurred just when he
was starting his company.
And so while he was a creator
of a great many things,
he was also an early adopter
of other people's technologies
and improvements.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah,
we had talked too.
So all of this
information-- this
is all incredibly
interesting stuff.
And the book is quite
thick and filled with lots
of tidbits of information.
We talked before we started.
This idea that there's
a lot of information
out there about John,
not so much about Will.
A lot of the
information in terms
of biographical information
and documentation around Will
is tightly controlled by the
Kellogg Foundation to this day
where you actually
have to sign a release
and potentially give--
not potentially, but actually
give them some final editing
rights to the information that
you pull from those documents
before they can be published.
How did you gather
so much information
in terms of-- again, you
mentioned John there's
quite a bit of information.
But with Will, how did you
pull all of that information
together?
You also mentioned
at the beginning
that this is a
bit of a departure
from your previous work
in terms of working on
some of the epidemics
and some of the books
that focus on that.
So what was that process
in terms of research
looked like for
you in this book?
And how did it differ
from the other books
that you've written?
HOWARD MARKEL: Yeah,
well, it is an issue that
the Kellogg Foundation,
which owns the Kellogg,
Will's papers--
and they're beautifully
archived and lovingly kept.
You can't get to them unless
you sign such a release.
And no serious writer
or historian can do so.
Fortunately, Will wrote
thousands, millions of memos,
which went to other people.
You can get a sense
of his advertising
and work from the actual ads.
And he sued a great many
people and would be deposed.
And there's just
stacks of depositions
that are taller than I am.
And so you got a great
sense of his life,
and who he was,
how he spoke, how
he fought with other people.
So while it wasn't
perfect, I could create
a rounded portrayal of him.
There are also memoirs
of him by his grandson,
privately printed memoirs that
we have at the Bentley library.
So I was lucky to be able
to get access to that.
And there are a few
biographies and such that
had been written in the '50s.
They're corporate biographies.
But they were not unhelpful.
They actually were very helpful.
So how did I do this
compared to my other books?
In a very similar process.
First of all, you find people
or events that has a great paper
trail, and not everyone keeps
paper, particularly today,
but even back then.
When you design
an experiment, you
have to make sure there
the experiment can be done.
And so if there's no archival
material, you can't do that.
Now in this case, there was
tons of archival material
even with the limitation
we just discussed.
And then you just jump
in and you read paper.
And the more paper you read,
the more ideas you get.
And it's sort of like
swimming in a deep lake.
You don't know where you are.
You don't know
where you're going.
And then suddenly, thankfully,
at least in my experience,
you have this moment that's
how it's going to be.
And then I told
this to my editor
at the time when I was going to
change the focus from just John
Harvey Kellogg to the brothers.
She goes, oh, I knew you were
going to do that all the time.
I said, well, you
could've at least told me.
You would have saved
me about eight months.
As a writer, you figure it out.
I've always been
very blessed with--
I don't believe
in writer's block.
I believe in not
wanting to write.
I write every day even
if I throw it out.
I'm always interested
in reading about people
and writing about them.
And so the more you
play with the topic--
play is not the precise word.
The more you work with
the topic you've chosen,
you figure it out.
You figure it out.
And it [INAUDIBLE] jigsaw puzzle
work because you're trying
to create--
at least I do when
I write books.
I'm what's called a
narrative historian.
I really want to convey a
story with a beginning, middle,
and ab end to my readers.
These are the stories
I like to read.
And I hope my readers
like them as well.
JASON ANDREAS: And with such
a deeply researched book like
the Kellogg's--
I'm just curious myself--
what's like the
split of time you
spend researching to
time you spent writing?
I'm asking because it seems
like you did a ton of research
on this, and digging
through these stacks,
and not necessarily having
access to Will's papers,
and having to go in a roundabout
way to find other methods,
and reading through these piles
of letters and depositions.
Did that take longer
than your previous books?
Was there more
research that went
into this because of some of
the slight difficulties in
finding this?
So what's the time average on--
I'm just curious as to
what that might look like.
HOWARD MARKEL:
Well, my first book
was about two epidemics in
1892 within seven months
of each other.
And it took me seven
years to write.
But even though there was
a lot of research done,
it wasn't a long period of time.
And this book was my
longest and most complicated
book because it covers
almost 100 years of history
from about 1830--
actually, more than 100
years-- to about 1951.
And there's a great many
changes that are going on.
So first, you get the paper.
First, you get the
archival materials.
And then you start reading
it either on microfilm or I
like the hard copy.
And then you start taking notes,
and thinking about things,
and reading more,
and reading more.
It took me about two years
of just reading paper.
And then I figured
out where I was going.
And then I started writing it.
Now I'm a rewriter.
I write things over and
over and over again.
And for people out there
who want to be a writer,
I became a published writer
when I started rewriting.
And I rewrite things 10, 20, 30,
40 times, probably even more.
JASON ANDREAS: Wow.
HOWARD MARKEL: And I will
play with a sentence.
And I'm just lucky
that I enjoy that.
I actually like
playing with sentences
and trying to make things
more clear, or more
exciting, or more interesting.
And so it took another
three years to write.
But actually this book
from start to finish
took only five years.
JASON ANDREAS: Less than.
HOWARD MARKEL: And I told
you that first book--
JASON ANDREAS: Seven, yeah.
HOWARD MARKEL: --20 years ago
or 25 years ago took seven.
So maybe I'm getting
better at it.
I don't know.
JASON ANDREAS: Did
your writing style
have to change for
this book since it
was a bit of a departure from
these stories of epidemics?
Did you change
your writing style
or did you keep the same style.
Just changed the
story a little bit?
HOWARD MARKEL: I
think the latter.
I mean, you can't help
but create a writing style
if you write a great deal.
And I do.
I wrote for "The New
York Times" for 10 years.
Now I write for "PBS NewsHour."
And I wrote for "Science
Friday" for many years.
And I've written many books.
And I also have written for
academic audiences as well as
a professor.
And over a period
of time, you develop
a way of expressing yourself.
And I think I've
gotten better at that.
I feel a greater command
of the pen, so to speak,
on this my eighth
or ninth book--
I've lost count-- than
I was 20 years ago.
I feel I know what I'm doing.
But the process is very similar.
It's never really changed.
And what also has
never changed--
I bring as much joy to my desk
in the morning this morning
as I did 25 years ago.
JASON ANDREAS: That's great.
What's next?
I don't mean to rush you along.
I know this book just--
I believe it came
out in mid 2017.
HOWARD MARKEL: Yeah,
came out last summer.
JASON ANDREAS: Last summer.
Yeah, so we're about
12 months past release.
Are you working on something?
Are you taking time off?
You said, you're always writing.
So that's [INAUDIBLE]
HOWARD MARKEL: I start a
book as soon as I finish one.
JASON ANDREAS:
Almost immediately.
HOWARD MARKEL: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: Never ending.
HOWARD MARKEL: It's a
magnificent obsession.
JASON ANDREAS: Can
you share with us?
HOWARD MARKEL: Yeah, sure.
It's funny.
Whenever you do a book
talk by the way, invariably
the question is, what's next?
Well, I want to talk
about this book.
JASON ANDREAS:
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]..
You had mentioned
you write every day.
And sometimes I throw it away.
And that actually kind of
connected the question.
Is there something that's out
of that writing every day?
HOWARD MARKEL: I'm just
starting a new book now
on the discovery of
the structure of DNA,
which is a great story.
I was fortunate
enough in October
to be a research fellow at
the Rockefeller Foundation
Center in Bellagio.
I love saying I was in Bellagio.
JASON ANDREAS: Not the
casino in Las Vegas.
HOWARD MARKEL: No, no,
no, no, no, the real one.
JASON ANDREAS: Like
Lake Como [INAUDIBLE]..
HOWARD MARKEL: Lake Como.
And the view from my room--
JASON ANDREAS: Both
very beautiful.
HOWARD MARKEL: Oh, the
view I had from my room
was just incredible.
And I would read.
I thought to
myself, what's next?
And I thought of
writing a long big book
of American medical history.
But it was too
choppy and episodic.
And as I was saying, I'm
a narrative historian.
It's sort of like the equivalent
of a short story collection
as opposed to a novel
when you're telling
a longer type of a story.
And I thought to myself, well,
are there any light switch
moments that everyone
sort of understands
that changed everything
in terms of how
we understand the human body?
Because I'm a physician
and historian in medicine.
And I had just taught
to my medical students--
before I left, we have a
class I call Great Papers,
sort of great books.
And we take great papers
from the history of medicine
and talk about them
and what the context,
the historical times
were, and so on.
And we read the Watson and
Crick paper from "Nature"
in 1953, which is an
amazingly short paper.
It's 900 words.
And there's not a
scintilla of data.
It's all theory.
It was the work of
Wilkins and Franklin
that did the X-ray
crystallography studies that
proved Watson and Crick's theory
correct about the double helix.
And there's several books
about the double helix,
mostly by participants.
And the more I read,
I thought, this really
needs a more fully-rounded
historical account.
And my literary agent
and my publisher
agreed, which is
always a good feeling.
JASON ANDREAS: That's good.
HOWARD MARKEL: And, in
fact, in a couple of weeks,
I'll be meeting with Dr.
Watson to interview him.
So I'm just thrilled--
JASON ANDREAS: Oh,
that's exciting.
HOWARD MARKEL: --to
have that chance.
And, of course, I've been
going through the archives
quite a bit.
I was in England for
about a month and a half
at Cambridge where
they did their work
and a lot of the
participants papers are
as well as U. London.
And I'll be going to
Cold Spring Harbor where
Dr. Watson's papers are.
And then I'll get to Dr. Crick's
papers, which are in San Diego.
So I'm having a ball.
And I just started it.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah, so
you're early in that research
phase of just absorbing
as much as you can
and trying to figure out
where the story takes you.
HOWARD MARKEL: Exactly.
And somebody once asked, well,
what part of writing a book
do you like?
And, well, I like them all.
And so I like this
phase that I'm doing.
Writing is not-- there's
this romantic view.
When I go to a party, people
go, well, I have a book in me.
And I often think, well, maybe
that's where it should stay.
But, yeah, writing is hard work.
But it's wonderful work.
I love the writing.
I love the rewriting.
I love the editing process,
working with a good editor.
I love when it's set in galleys.
You can start to see
what it's looking like.
I love talking about
it once it's done.
So it beats a real job
any day of the week.
It's been a really good career.
JASON ANDREAS: That's awesome.
Well, we'll have to
have you back in when
the next book comes out.
Not to pressure you [INAUDIBLE]
HOWARD MARKEL: Give
me a couple of years.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: Call us in a few
years when it's ready to go.
HOWARD MARKEL: I will.
JASON ANDREAS: We'll
get you back in.
HOWARD MARKEL: Great, great.
JASON ANDREAS: Well, listen,
thank you, Dr. Markel.
Thank you for sharing.
Like I said, the
book is fantastic.
I really enjoyed
it front to back.
I really did.
Very historically relevant
and also relevant to
what's going on today.
There's so many pages
where I was like, oh, this
is tying so many
things together for me
that I hadn't known from
health and wellness all the way
to pop culture.
Very interesting
across the board.
Thanks for sharing.
Best of luck with
everything moving forward,
the research phase.
Thank you again for coming.
HOWARD MARKEL: Thank
you for having me.
JASON ANDREAS: We
really appreciate it.
HOWARD MARKEL:
Thank you very much.
JASON ANDREAS: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]